hello everybody its bill bird it's time
for another episode of the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast and I am just checking
in on you
seeing how you weeks going and and
whatnot I have some special guests this
week from an upcoming Hollywood motion
picture entitled the king of Staten
Island we have the great Ricky Velez who
I met while working on the film and then
the star of the film the golden boy who
hates compliments Pete Davidson what's
up guys hey man hey thank you so much
for coming on and we're we're basically
we're going to be the box office boys
today we're gonna promote the film Peter
when does it come out June comes out
June 12th on video on demand all right
well I got to tell you I've been getting
you know anytime I've had one of these
comes out you know there's always you
know I've been fortunate that most of
them have gotten positive reviews but
then there's always some people being
like well you need it on this I don't
understand that but this thing has been
overwhelmingly positive and I've gone on
a couple of podcast to where they kind
of love to [ __ ] on stuff and even they
were saying that they loved it so I
don't know guys I'm kind of excited
that really wasn't a question I just was
says I've never done by the way I've
never done the zoom thing with more than
one interviewee so I guess I have to
just sit here and go and go back and
forth so Pete I think people know who
you are at this point so Ricky I gotta
tell you dude I watched a ton of that
man I was [ __ ] blown away by your
acting chops man I thought she did a
great man you stood out in a very strong
strong I was actually mad I never got to
act with you those those that was
probably like the goal going into all of
it so just getting to work with you with
the writing was pretty sick but I wanted
to act alongside with Bill burr yeah you
you were with Pete's whole Staten Island
crew of uh yeah those guys so I'm you
guys I didn't even like I saw you
because you were writing on the thing so
I would see you then but I only I ran
into you guys that like the fitting and
I feel like one other day and then that
was kind of it but I don't know I think
the whole thing kind of came together so
I don't know you guys bummed out that
it's not gonna be didn't get to do a
premiere and all of that [ __ ] yeah I'm
bummed out because I've wanted to hang
with everybody I wanted to hang with
elves but we were just talking about all
right
I miss Elliot so bad man yeah for those
listening Robert Elswick was the direct
add the DP on it is that the right thing
what's the second tog refer
cinematographer and he's done everything
from there will be blood to that scene
where Tom Cruise is like on the outside
of the airplane he shot all of that
stuff and kind of became one of the I
did that for months he's all right all
right yeah all right all right you stand
over there he's gonna do this and then
the plane comes in and we're gonna shoot
it all right how casually Bob would hang
off a car as they were driving was
always hilarious to me like he was just
so okay with hanging off the side of a
car and filming something yeah he was a
B I don't know we I hope I get to work
with that guy again but I have to ask
you guys about Staten Island cuz I was
just there obviously doing the acting
gig and I left so everybody's been
asking me you know how I like Staten
Island I was saying I loved it it
reminded me sort of like Greater Boston
and a lot of the places where I used to
hang out when I was younger and I was
saying it seemed like a great place and
all I could hear was you guys sort of
laughing and I you know it seemed like a
nice suburban stuff and then I was
thinking in my head sort of the
storyline of what you guys were involved
in I'm probably need to spend some more
time there or am i a little of my kind
of right stat islands like a beautiful
piece of [ __ ] it's like come on what are
you talking about it's gorgeous it is it
no it's it's a beautiful like it has all
the views of like everything beautiful
but it itself is like it's just I don't
Ricki and what do you like compared to
I'm crossing Queens yeah I grew up in
Queens so I thought you were the Staten
Island bad boy that's what I was calling
you the whole Oh Queen sorry all right
I only saw the parts that Pete had shown
me and then like the people I knew out
of it were all like cops and whatnot
it's never like
before knowing Pete I probably had been
to the island like ten times you just
don't go there yeah I drove through it
once I was playing the stress factory
and my flight was out of JFK so I just
sort of shot over the bridge drove
through it over the Verrazano and then
that was it but I was surprised I
thought it was gonna look like Brooklyn
like I didn't realize it was gonna have
such a suburb vibe I thought it was
beautiful
my nuts there are no there are parts of
it that are stunning like some of the
houses that we mean were you in the
Graduate no you weren't
no but um there's a part in the film
where we filmed in one of the nicest
houses I've ever been in all other
graduation seem and you can see the
whole entire all of that the island of
MIT had a new study it was it was nuts I
mean that seems like to move though if
you're gonna live there you can get a
great house
you can like living in man
is cool but it sucks because you're
paying so much and then you can't see
the city you're just in it it's like
right up against your face but if you're
in Staten Island you can have a yard
you're just a couple of bridges away if
you drive you can jump on the little
ferry my overly simplifying this I
thought it was great no yeah I think
growing up there and it like like you
love where you grew up bill
yes no well yeah I I guess it's just
yeah but there was also like I grew up
in Massachusetts so was all connected so
there was no sort of the way you guys
are broken off there that as an island
that I think that you know needs to send
the trash out there I guess from the
Manhattan so I guess there is sort of a
stigma but it's all tops and
firefighters like it's it has to be a
good percentage of the FDNY and NYPD oh
so it's like Copland yeah yeah it's very
very blue-collar over here and the only
thing is is like people from Staten
Island I was explained they don't go to
the city like it's like living in Jersey
so like anytime you would go to the city
it would be like this big ridiculous
thing you know yeah and I would think
nowadays there's probably less reason to
go in there considering they just think
they scrubbed it clean it's just there's
no vibe it's very I'm surprised Kovac
survived in Manhattan how once all those
glass towers the Bed Bath & Beyond came
in I was kind of like am i walking
around New York not worried about
getting punched in the head for no
reason this I mean when I first moved
down there I was it was a it wasn't to
crack a tease but there was somewhere
along the line there was a tipping point
where it was fun in the beginning of the
90s and then that land of just took that
turn of Disney World I love it I love
being able to skip and hold hands 30
[Laughter]
I'm from the part of Queens that like as
far as far away as Peters from minute so
like it was always like anybody
went to Manhattan when in a limo oh yeah
it was like the big well how did you
guys end up meeting each other uh I was
20 21 when Pete was 16 yeah we do and uh
we were doing prom shows at New York
Comedy Club oh yeah yeah
and I was doing la bar were you on the
boat no he met in the comedy club and we
were doing prom shows for our schools
and that we would I would just eat it in
front of life and people know that when
would the balls to go in front of your
own classmates yeah it was a nightmare
and then I realized that I should just
make fun of like the principal's and
just be like yeah you know study hard it
became easier but I would just eat my
dick in front of everybody I grew up
with those are some of the worst shows I
ever had I will talk about all you know
that Philly's show you got booed by ten
thousand that's not that's nothing
[ __ ] prom gigs did I didn't stain up
New York had the ones you were on a boat
it was actually a really cool prom for
the kids until I started doing my comedy
but like they were on this boat going
around Manhattan I mean it was it was
gorgeous I mean they'd eat what the
school did to increase those kids
chances of getting laid was was
incredible they came in like the big you
know the big [ __ ] block hey we got a
comedy show
they just cut off the music have you
walk out onto the dance floor it was
just it was just a [ __ ] nightmare no
yeah I felt like I felt like they never
enjoyed the shows I felt like they just
wrote like ah another hour until I get
home and try like [ __ ] I was part
of the overprotecting of kids when that
began when they started having comedy
shows and knowing where they were all at
I did have one where the freshmen from
when I was seniors were it was their
graduation and they know it's hosting
and they booed me every time I went up
and even introduced somebody so they
just glued me back and forth the whole
entire you even had a chance no shot no
just me I was never cool enough to watch
it happen like the comics were coming
but be like
have to see this I was getting booed up
and down each 120x that night you next
act and we've all [ __ ] been there so
let and can you guys let my listeners
know because I'm gonna [ __ ] this up
where can we go to see this movie what
is the movie on it'll be on Apple it'll
be on your cable
it'll be on Amazon I believe it'll
anywhere that you can you know rent or
buy a movie it'll be like when they
release trolls we're trying to follow
the trolls world tour format I know it
was that crushed that watch the other
night with my kid about this old guy and
his wife dies you know it's Disney
somebody always has to die right
is it up yes yeah dad it's sad movie
it's like what are they trying to do to
you like the [ __ ] you know he finds
love he finds his weight and that just
says do the cutest couple ever then all
of a sudden they show her it that
they're painting like stuff on the wall
like they're gonna have a kid and then
they just show her it the doctor crying
and I'm like did she have a miscarriage
is this like is this is a storyline in a
[ __ ] Disney movie a miscarriage I got
explain this my daughter is like going
she's sad and then I had my knee and you
explain to me what happened I got she
have a miscarriage like no no they just
said she's barren she can't have any
kids how come they don't have that ride
at Disney that one they don't have they
don't have Remember the Titans that was
a that was a Disney movie they need to
make those rides and I'll go yeah so yes
we watched that thing and yeah I got
pretty intense man on all of a sudden
that guy just he started to try to kill
him and there was the the asian kid
there who's sort of a kidnapping that he
should maybe should have turned the
house around but they kind of kept going
with this that little Cub Scout kid it
was always it was still a good movie but
there was a lot of feet and I thought
were a little beyond like three and a
half year old because she kept is that
Annie
some olga guy i balloons to his house
and i took the kid to south america not
only that he's up in the clouds he gets
into [ __ ] IFR that's my favorite
thing ever right he has no gauges or
anything but it's also like he's not
really staring it so he's gonna be fine
but then the [ __ ] kid is out on the
front porch for like half the ride and i
got to be honest because i'm not trying
to be the [ __ ] weekend warrior here
but he would have got high poxy he would
have died
you can't [ __ ] go up there that lets
out uh I forget the test I think it's
above twelve five you got to have some
sort of assisted oxygen this little kid
was [ __ ] out on the porch he got down
to like Nicaragua before he realized
that [ __ ] kid was hanging out there I
know it's just a movie but Jesus Christ
and he's going like those are
cumulonimbus him in my head I'm going oh
you want to get away from that that's
like the worst [ __ ] ever on the test
bring me on a [ __ ] dc-10 Ricky you
had a kid right yeah man I actually did
watch that movie but my kids not old
enough to like understand death that was
actually going to be my question for you
that your kid like understand someone
die she understands that somebody's sad
and and there was the initial I remember
the first time she sort of saw someone
who was being a jerk in a movie and it
was just confusing because everybody's
been so like positive and loving her and
all of that so she was just like she
just kept away he do that dad done why
that man knew that it would have he not
a good guy and I know he's not he's not
a good guy I read it in this old book
was Robert MacLeod ski books and it's
about the kid who plays the harmonica
there's some old guy in town was just an
[ __ ] old sneak and whenever I grabbed
the book lentils the name of the book
should just be like I'll read me let's
all be like all right and as I pick up
the book she look at me she like all
Steve not a good guy so anyway so okay
so it's gonna be up on all the platforms
I tell you I think you guys got
yourselves a
this feels like it's gonna be a really
thick you got I'm not trying to jinx it
or anything you guys did a hell of a job
just fun to be a part of this was sick I
mean there's really come on ready we got
45 minutes you go you got to sell it
harder than that I'm so bad I'm so bad
at doing this price I might get like 50
of them at this point and after the
Washington Post one I mean that guy did
really in-depth questions yeah I was
like when your dad died did it make you
sad I was like it actually did and he
goes when you were watching the fires
and stuff did that make you sad as well
it's like yeah it did miss a guy I know
that that job is to try to bring the
emotion out I told you my wife watches
that when she watches those those murder
shows late at night and they'll have
like the the reporter is interviewing
the person who lost a loved one
and he's just watching the guys job of
the woman's job to pull the tears out
it's just it's it's horrific like so do
you miss him do you think about him
every day what was the last thing he
said to you it's just Jesus Christ why
don't you just hold him anymore
how'd you guys see the NHL's gonna come
back yeah they're gonna do a playoff in
two cities yet to be determined
depending on your record there's gonna
be a best three out of five in the first
round like the old days which means you
know the the lower ranked team all they
gotta do is win that game one and then
it becomes like you know the other team
tightens up it's actually a great thing
I don't know if they're gonna have fans
or anything but I'm kind of feeling like
everybody's just ignoring the government
now and just sort of uncor intoning
themselves so just like I've had it I
can't be in the [ __ ] house anymore
yeah yeah I haven't seen many people
with masks lately everybody's trying to
drop the whole mask thing walking around
Manhattan and people do not have masks
on there's numerous people not wear
masks in New York it's crazy I feel it's
insane
yeah well I'm still a mascot I'm just
like until the CDC says don't wear one
I'm not gonna listen to somebody who
doesn't have a [ __ ] medical degree
EDC told you not to wear one oh they did
it well I also don't watch they were
their original people of town where
though they said don't wear one
originally the CDC said not to wear them
what does that mean did they then change
it they changed their minds on them yeah
when they'd all started masks were dumb
it was a dumb move what you should wear
them you're putting that out there like
that's why we listen to the people that
don't tell you the right I'm just I'm
not listening to anybody I'm picking my
own rules and I'm sticking to them oh
well I mean I don't know all I know is
whenever Asians get sick they wear them
and they they seem to be like the ones
that know what's going on they seem to
know they just get it come here I
remember they would be wearing masks on
the plane I'm like what are they doing
then I realize oh it's because they have
a cold I'm like that is like some of the
most thoughtful courteous [ __ ] I've ever
seen in my life where they live like you
ain't gonna [ __ ] tell me to wear a
mask you [ __ ] special this sumbitch
listen I get people who live in the
minute middle of [ __ ] nowhere you
know I was talking to a buddy of mine
lives in Tennessee he goes it's not like
the way it is in LA in New York it's not
like that out here our neighbors are not
on top of us so you know I I get that I
guess
you guys gonna do one of these comedy
club gigs were they you know 300 tables
looks like four people sitting there now
I'm terrified that sounds so scary to do
right now what about you are you good
thinking about doing any of those things
I would do it I got a kid coming in like
two weeks so like I can't really do it
but I I would do it I go a lot I would
just like lose money they're like yeah
you know they got a couple in Utah
Arizona or something and I'm just
sitting there going like all right this
is gonna be how many people there and I
have to fly all the way out there and do
all of this [ __ ] I don't know if I'm
gonna make any money but I think I'm
just gonna use I think I'm gonna do some
local [ __ ] out here in LA I'm gonna find
some random little theaters or whatever
just go up you know work for free let
the theater of charge whatever they want
to charge so they can stay afloat like I
want to do one at the The Troubadour I'd
like to do one down there because I know
they're kind of hurting it's a famous
music venue out here so I don't know I
guess stuff like that but the great
thing is if the quarantine stays hey is
something [ __ ] up what if everybody
just uncor intents and says [ __ ] this
we're going out then what happens with
you would you feel any responsibility if
like a group of people got sick at your
show well that's a great question and
it's an easy answer no I wouldn't I
don't have to apologize to any more than
I do have to do my jokes you know we
were in a pandemic you decided to so
what am i I was like so mesmerizing that
you just had to walk down to the club to
[ __ ] I'm so sick of people not taking
responsibility okay we all know what the
game is we rolled the dice you lost
we're in the crowd
I was far enough away I would definitely
perform at the back of the stage like on
stage like the door opens like the old
Miami improv like the greatest play the
comedy comes with you you walk off stage
immediately go right to the rain room
we're the greatest service that's like
the late shows if you had a problem with
drunk guy and you're like I really don't
feel like getting sucker-punched you
could just want I didn't I maybe I would
do something like that but Miami's one
they just opened oh yeah you're not gay
those people that too good-looking they
work out too hard they want to show it
off you know they're gonna open the
restaurants in New York City on the
streets oh they are and where you're
sort of sneeze out towards the street I
don't know I have no idea but I will
tell you this I have such a great time
working on this movie with you guys and
I am really really bummed out that there
is no sort of premiere because I was
looking forward to getting together with
all the the firefighters again to have
Mario tell me some more of his acting
stories there was a guy I'm not gonna
say what this story was but he just
repeatedly kept telling stories of these
these horrible characters that he played
and what he did in these friggin movies
man it was just a guy dude I got it I
got her and he was so proud of it like
he could have always in a horror movie
and I got to drown a baby it's like okay
I get it like really convincing okay
Mario you for the rest of this film
would you call him the red flag we had a
nickname for him I forgot what it was
but we had a nickname from every time he
popped up we would go up red flags over
here no I worked on the one with the guy
you know when he would walk over to
where we were sitting we would just
start chanting HR just like dude I don't
know what do you think it's too 70s well
I'm just talking I'm [ __ ] oh man he
was hilarious
so when you guys think back up again
what's that when do you think the comedy
clubs will up and back up again in New
York or LA like I think in LA they'll
open I think New York or not open the
longest yeah I think I think Christmas
I think August you think August
well look at all these [ __ ] lunatic
like I love that whole wave of people
that went down to the beach
god bless those people god bless him
like that's all you know he's old
footage and those GIS are walking
towards that a bomb they just set off so
they could see what was gonna happen
less poor bastards right I feel like
those people did that for the covin they
went down pioneers
yeah they twerked and snorkeled rode
their [ __ ] four-wheelers past each
other coffin all over each other you
know if they [ __ ] survive I think
it's safe to come out I mean George is
not spiking oh they're not oh dude [ __ ]
this we're gonna do a tour by September
fine the uncertainty is is that there's
definitely sucks though just not knowing
is really annoying not knowing the fact
that it's gonna come back and now that
it's like hitting kids that's what sucks
yeah I saw that is that like it's that
becoming a thing I mean not enough
number-wise to be a big big thing but I
mean there are kids that are getting
stuff that are Kobi positive yeah yeah
so there's probably not a lot of them
but it's enough to get people stirred up
and scared so the 20 yeah like our
pediatrician here in New York hit us up
and was just telling us like the facts
of it other than what the news was
telling us and it's like it's bad but
it's definitely not the worst it's not
as bad the attrition that he hit you up
you'd have to like talk to him or
something like that text messages and
[ __ ] all right so let's let's talk more
about the movie here what's uh how do
you talk about a movie you don't want to
give away favorite scenes um dan it's
one of yours bill all right when you
show up to the house yeah it's my
favorite scene in the whole movie he
[ __ ] laughs so hard dude that's the
that was the first my first day on that
I remember yeah I had to scream and yell
at you and Marissa okay really weird hey
Marissa I love this meet you what the
[ __ ] is wrong
jumping in with both feet I think Jed
did that on purpose in a good way
no yeah everything he does has a rhyme
or reason what was your favorite scene I
liked the one where we were playing not
cards although they only used it a real
clip a quick one I just had that in like
the baseball because I figured by then
we had all like bonded right I was going
to work and I just felt like I was just
hanging out with friends and [ __ ]
so yeah there was a lot of stuff
there'll be a lot of extras a lot of
things that they cut that I was just
like man that didn't make it but then I
saw the movies like 2 hours and 15
minutes long so I'm like alright well
like yeah you had to cut something at
that point yeah that so the first cut
was like 247 I was like anything oh yeah
we did that's right over and over at
Judds offices did we snug the towers
enough yeah we smoked cigars I thought
he told us not to smoke in his office so
I thought I didn't I went outside didn't
I yeah we went outside yeah you complied
[ __ ] sad basset hound eyes I wasn't I
just pictured him the next day they
smoked in here slumped he goes like
editing babe posture right that's just
like anymore fold it over than he
already is go ahead I was just laughing
is this the hardest [ __ ] interview
ever because you guys are not here and
then the thing that we're supposed to
talk about you can't really talk about
because you can't [ __ ] give it away
yeah these zoom things are a nightmare
they they're they have have you how many
of you dumbbell I've done a lot I like
zoom as far as like not having to
commute anywhere and not being another
[ __ ] going to an airport or being in
the car I like being out of the way of
other people knowing that because I'm
not there is another there's a guy
sitting at a red light who's at least a
car lengths ahead you know so I'm hoping
after the end of all this [ __ ] that
we finally utilize especially like all
these business meetings and [ __ ] oh yeah
like this all these like when I started
doing the road youngsters like that was
the very beginning of just everybody
started traveling like when I was a kid
if you traveled that was like a special
things like it was like one guy in every
neighborhood who was a big big [ __ ]
business guy who had to take a business
trip and it was like wow he gets a
company car he puts on a suit he goes to
the airport gets on [ __ ] Eastern
Airlines or whatever the hell he did but
everybody else it was like maybe the
rich family in your neighborhood like
took him to like [ __ ] Disneyland in
like this Disney World in the summertime
and they come back everybody was all
tanned up and [ __ ] and had all their
Mickey Mouse stuff now you just would
say I remember asking my friend when I
was a kid I was just asking I didn't
know what it looked like I knew there
was a castle that was it I was like what
and he was telling me he was
exaggerating all this [ __ ] said he went
to a haunted house there was a trapdoor
and he fell through it and I was fine
and there was no way to go on the
Internet in fact check and I was like
really my mom go we need to go to Disney
World there's a haunted house with a
trapdoor and you fall through it I don't
think that when you get a little older
when you get a little older we'll do
something like that yeah yeah that was
the vacation once every like two three
years that was that was my big thing
Ricky do you have to go on vacation we
camped a lot we did a lot of camping
like that big early like I went to the
Bahamas once yeah that's a that's a big
one we went to Disney World
when I was like 15 we finally took a
family oh maybe a little before that I
went to young I barely remember it I
went when in Washington DC we did that
and I remember one of my little brother
got lost like we were looking at the
White House when you could like walk up
to the gate and like wave to the
president before [ __ ] 9/11 and so on
March Sadat given given give a speech
and then my brother was just gone
I mean gone gone to the point I was
having a panic attack I thought he was
gone a minute I did help finding him I
still remember was the early 80s and he
had his white socks pulled up to his
knees with the Larry Bird short shorts
with that line going down the side we
saw honey yeah I was so [ __ ] relieved
Austin just ran away well I mean there
was no cell phones and [ __ ] so if you
just drifted away it was like you were
on the Serengeti an alligator came up
onto the water and you were just gone it
was like the amount of kids that I'm
shot I know that just and I'm telling
you you could have been like [ __ ] 10
feet away from your family but that
there was a crowd and then they panic
and the herd just starts stampeding
looking for the kid you go in different
directions and you had a [ __ ] problem
that's crazy but back to the uplifting
movie that we're all in you know you
said something really cool in that that
DC thing where you say now you feeling
like you're you're gonna be able to put
all of this behind you finally I was
really happy for you as far as that when
did I'm hoping that people will you got
to come up with a great line after this
any time they after they try to steer
you back into that [ __ ] something about
how you know I made a movie about it
and wanted to say it's in that movie and
I would really appreciate it if he took
the time to check it out because that's
that's rather than answer this question
it the whole entire zoom thing has been
really difficult for me because I can't
sit still I'm like horrible I like to
pace so I've had a horrible time doing
like all these like interviews on
this one's fun but all the fluids have
been as I thank you I thought you are
all comfortable there you Commissioner
Gordon leather chair that you have that
is a man's [ __ ] chair right there
that is a guy that is making decisions
thank you I feel like I should have a
big button over here I wander Neath the
desk yeah oh yeah I guess those jokes
aren't funny anymore in this art that
really kind of slowed that all down
right Owen I wonder if that does that
come does that come right back cuz
there's a weird time right now where
yeah the hold me to thing right yet all
of that [ __ ] and then Kovac comes along
knocks them up the front page
and now you've had these horrible you
know stories about people of color and
cops and all of that type of things and
you know people telling you know white
women to put their dogs on leashes so
that Karen thing has now gone
it's gone viral and white women are now
aware of what that is there was white
women it was Karen's and that type of
[ __ ] so now what I'm wondering is now
their next move is going to be to show
how woke they now they're actually white
women are on the defensive I feel like
right now for the first time in about
five years
they had a great run you know the team's
old like the last dance you know now
they could be you know so-and-so's last
year complaining I love the last dance
they're that how great was that just
watching Dennis Rodman go wrestle in the
middle of the finals it just seems so
sick what about having it Jordan Jordan
like literally goes to go get him like
how bad this guy wants to win he's
knocking on the door and Carmen
Electra's pulling the covers up over a
head it's so sick now they're just like
I thought you know this there's been a
number of sports writers there we don't
like a documentary that the guy is a
good guy the whole time now I think that
says a lot about you Ricky
I'm [ __ ] with you but that's what a
lot of like people who criticize me like
well he had final edit it was a fluff
piece and it's like buddy you guys have
been telling his story for 40 [ __ ]
years
chill out it wouldn't be great to hear
his version yeah Wittering you tried to
make like his dad's murder about his
gambling which was beyond he should have
been able to sue them for libel or
whatever the [ __ ] you do blasphemy or
pandemic C's or whatever the [ __ ] you
call it right he shouldn't be able to
sue for something there's actually some
guy he's really whining about it but he
also has a that he wasn't in it but he
also has a book coming out so I think
he's trying to use whatever momentum of
that thing to sell his book but uh I
think I don't know I think sports
writers had their opportunities story in
real time and now he's like no this is
the story and I just loved Isaiah Thomas
going on and doing that whole damage
control press thing yeah oh yeah all
that [ __ ] but he threw the Celtics
under the bus and all that he's like
yeah people didn't shake hands you know
it's like well Jordan did two years in a
row and when you finally beat the
Celtics because you didn't have a stupid
inbound pass that Larry Byrd took stole
you were running over to shake Kevin
McHale's hands so you obviously shake
hands if you win so they decide if
they're doing the NBA in Disney what is
that I heard they're bringing the NBA
back at Disney World
really yeah that would be insane
Mickey Mouse doing backflips at halftime
now dude it's gonna be nobody but the
team's there and they're saying the
Knicks might not even get to go because
their records are so bad it'll just be
the teams that are qualifying for the
playoffs
wait a minute they're gonna play the
playoffs and Disney World
possibly yeah it we're though it's a
small world after all they're gonna
clear out the rides like whatever
stadium yeah oh the world yeah okay
we're gonna be playing like out in this
like Main Street No
no they're gonna play
they the decision was like last week I
believe tiny MBA there Walt Disney World
Hotel accommodations
yeah they're gonna be playing Disney
favorite teams mask and show up
complimentary vitamin D as you enter the
arena how many are they gonna let people
go in or no no no no all right they're
just gonna finish off the season yeah it
says NBA Lakers for July return at
Disney World
so the Lakers will win the finals well
they should just go right to the
playoffs cuz if they play the rest of
the regular season I mean and then they
start next year's regular season they're
gonna be playing like a [ __ ] year and
a half straight although they did have a
nice offseason right now but like are
you gonna like end who the like the guys
gonna win the championship and like the
end of [ __ ] August and start playing
like preseason games mid-september
yeah huh it's gonna be all playoffs
that's gonna be fun we'll be making its
return under this format instead the NBA
will effectively end its regular season
in favor of the postseason format will
be similar to any other NBA playoff the
top eight teams from the conference will
go against each other in a tournament
with the eastern and western
conference's facing finals right now one
of the odds three half-court guy from
Toronto the rapper the fan Oh Drake
Drake one of the Luck's he still gets in
[Laughter]
a lot of sports without crowds even that
that Tom Brady Peyton Manning Tiger
Woods Phil Mickelson thing the fact that
you could hear him talking and they were
miked up was way cooler then listen to
some fat [ __ ] Tiger tees off dude
tiger you the man or in the hole and I
like an agony I could hear the guy works
at the Waffle House but I can't hear
like the greatest golfer of all time I
like I kind of like the USC with no
crowd who's [ __ ] killin - just hearing
the sound of those leg kicks and the
punches I mean I want the crowd to come
back because that's obviously I missed
the crowd of UFC I like that crowd I did
I mean Golf I don't watch but the UFC
crowd watching that kind of just felt
weird without the crowd did you feel
though thought that the hits with it
just just to hear them it's it sounded
even more cuz I'll sit there and watch a
guy check I kept looking at the empty
seats the whole [ __ ] fight huh
that's what you young guys all do like
you postive you post any picture on the
internet it's never about that with the
[ __ ] subject it's like hey great
picture but what's up with the [ __ ]
hinge up I don't know Home Depot much
it's just like jesus [ __ ] christ
sitting there nitpicking like a [ __ ]
American 10,000 people missing it's not
nitpicking fair enough but like there's
two guys trying to beat the [ __ ] out of
you and you're sitting there going look
at those empty seats I mean if you saw
two guys fighting on the street E you're
looking at the store that they're
fighting in front of what are they gonna
repair that awning seeing this [ __ ] I'm
not gonna lie when I watch old boxing
matches I was watching that guy who's a
dude yeah I remember the prince in the
seat in the seam or something like that
I was a piece of [ __ ] yeah was he he
like come in on a magic carpet yeah he
was selling the fight he was an
incredible show meaning to hit he's a
science man you gotta sell the fight you
mean being a [ __ ] [ __ ] makes
people want to see you get knocked out
and that dude people just could not
[ __ ] hit him until finally you know
we keep the barrera guy was just not
having it was just not [ __ ] having it
so you loved
Tyson Fury's entrance into the ring when
he did the whole case
and all the when he fought Wilder I
think it's ridiculous but I respect the
business side of it I mean first of all
the guy's gonna go in there's gonna get
hit in the head even if he wins like a
[ __ ] a hundred times and he's gonna
pay for that later on in life he needs
to be bigger than life so he can get
like you know some advertising gigs
selling Cheerios or something so he
could patent bank account
maybe quit or he runs into his Antonio
Tarver who's just younger and faster
like like the fight game is such a cruel
game as far as how the crowd like judges
you on your last fight when you're like
38 you like old enough to have like a 15
year old you know and if you you know
the average 38 year old it became
walking on the front lawn with his
[ __ ] wife beater and his spare tire
hanging over his is got these guys that
still fight at that level then they got
to fight some 22 year old kid I mean
yeah that's true you want to see Tyson
fight again you wanna see Mike Tyson
fight again I you know I don't you know
getting it seems like if you get hit
that the older you are the more damage
it can do I've enjoyed Tyson's
post-fight career his one-man show was
killer is uh you know some of his
podcast with Joe Rogan has had him on
he's a really fascinating guy so I don't
know I don't I don't want to see that
guy get knocked around I'm not saying
he's gonna get knocked around but just
you know fighting you got to take a few
to give a few I mean he's got to be like
50 right he's yeah he's like fifty three
or four but that training video he'd
that came out recently was [ __ ] wild
oh yeah I see that
he's unbelievable nobody ever had that
movement that he has at the heavyweight
division and the speed and the minute he
trains he just puts on the shortest pair
of pants he has it's insane he's Grant
Lee Daisy Duke swingin it's amazing
that's the old-school boxing short space
to go right up to your dick and he was a
historian I remember when he when he
first was a champion he was showing all
these those Jack Johnson fights and all
of that [ __ ] back then
Jack Johnson before he became a a white
folk singer or whatever that guy I had a
banana pancakes guy wasn't there again
isn't this huh there's a music yeah some
barefoot guy with a guitar named Jack
Johnson yeah and all the women loved him
and he [ __ ] lives in Hawaii I
remember reading the bottom and in
Rolling Stone like this guy we all
bought guitars but this guy figured it
out anybody can tickle the ivories but
can you write a hit song there anyway
well the movie comes out June 12th as I
mentioned and as much as I want this
quarantine to end it be great if
everyone was still inside and watched it
how's that that's beautiful bill I loved
it what is next for you
oh I'm just sitting in my mom's house
until this ends that's not it I got I
got nothing i got nothing i'm playing
video games and hoping that the world
gets better do you got you guys tour to
get you guys work together yeah we work
a lot together and this has been i think
this is the longest I haven't seen Pete
in 10 years it's crazy
what are you what you quarantine it in
Queens
no I'm hadn't been had it I actually I
parted I just realized you're wearing a
hat that said Queens and I said before
yeah you're from Staten Island I'm a
[ __ ] idiot sorry and I talked over
you like I always do so go ahead
no it's why I actually took off to
Michigan I was in Michigan for a while
my wife's from there so we stayed out
there for like 55 days and then we
recently came back within the last three
weeks and I just being back in the city
it's just weird here so I've just been
in Manhattan and then I'm gonna make a
move in a bit there's one of the best
gigs in the country is in Michigan I
think it's the outside of Grand Rapids
this there's a church that's still
functioning but on Saturday night they
just I don't know what religious
denomination they are but it's
definitely a cool religion because they
let us come in
either that and I hurting for money but
they let us come in and just say
whatever we want like you're up there on
the altar go hey what the [ __ ] up and
then the next day there's somebody up
there going like Jesus or Mohammed
whatever whatever they're into said this
and said that what the hell's the name
of that gig it's amazing it has like an
upper deck going around the whole top
that's what I loved about on my pot
lease these preachers are a draw out
here
just [ __ ] packing them in he became a
theatre act right it's awesome all right
with that love I think we've reached the
end here can sit here I can talk about
something you're not allowed to talk
about all right well before we get out
of here I want to thank I want to thank
you guys for coming on Pete thanks so
much for getting me in the movie and
you're the [ __ ] man dude thank you
you're awesome yeah you're this chair
and I'm looking yeah you guys are gonna
this big big shit's gonna happen for
both you guys Rick you guys gotta watch
Ricky Velez in this thing thank you
little natural man [ __ ] you crush
those scenes
I was watching my [ __ ] act like
you've been doing it for 20 years I see
a lot of work for you guys in the future
so just let me play the uncle the angry
old guy
I love being typecast because it means
I'm working all right that's it I gotta
go I gotta go
[ __ ] I got to do it like another
ninety one of these things so that's
that's the podcast here and who do I
have to stay on and do the yeah read
right all right here we go okay in here
okay today's Thursday's podcast was
brought to you by honey
are we still quarantine with all shop on
we all shop online a lot but did you
know you can make online shopping even
better you can with oh honey honey is
the free online shopping tool that saves
you money online honey
automatically finds the best promo codes
and applies them to your cart which
makes online shopping finally feel as
easy as its supposed to be
imagine you're shopping
one of your favorite sites oh I don't
know Target Best Buy Sephora Macy's eBay
Etsy Walmart etc I don't know if that's
a cetera they listed so many I think
those people you know that's product
placement right there etc is after two
or three when you check when you check
out this little drop this little box
drops down and all you have to do is
click apply coupons wait a second for it
to scan for every promo code on the
internet watch the prices drop honey is
found it's over eighteen million members
over two billion dollars in savings did
you know that honey supports over thirty
thousand stores online and they're
adding more every day
users love honey that's why it has over
a hundred thousand five-star reviews on
Google Chrome store on the google cruz
chrome store [ __ ] not using honey is
literally passing up free money it's
free to use and installs in just a few
seconds plus it's backed by PayPal so
you know you can trust it get honey for
free at join honey calm / / that's join
honey dot-com / / alright that's it
everybody
thank you so much for listening once
again the king of Staten Island starring
Pete Davidson
Marisa Tomei Steve Buscemi and
introducing the wonderful Ricky Velez
and it's gonna be streaming everywhere
enjoy the music and listen to a bonus
half-hour episode of a previous Greatest
Hits Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast hey what's
going on it's Bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday May
28th 2012 how's it going oh happy
Memorial Day huh thanks to all the
troops you know that's what you're
supposed to do today right anybody and
you're still recovering from the cookout
your cookout for the troops your 12-pack
to the head for the [ __ ] heroes I
don't give a [ __ ] what a holiday is I
don't give a [ __ ] what it
for eventually enough years goes by and
it's just an excuse to become a Tubba
[ __ ] and drink a 12-pack you know and
get all your feelings off your chest you
know all that [ __ ] that you've been
hovering about the person that you with
you know a few weeks ago somebody was
asking me I you know they wanted to
break up with somebody and I was saying
listen you got to listen you know the
person who has it down how to do the
breakup was minivan men podcasts own
celebrity star al Madrigal but if you
don't have time to email al Madrigal
just listen to LL Cool J big old but I
don't know why I'll never really listen
to him when I was growing up you know
mama said knock you out oh did she is
that what she said LL Cool J I don't
care you know I just wasn't into it in
his deodorant in his armpits when he was
jamming with those white guys I just I
never got into it but lately I don't
know I don't know what happened I just
just come on to my YouTube shed I don't
know what it is but I was listening to
some of his stuff well I know why
yesterday I was trying to remember like
what was that song he used to have that
I'm the type of guy and you're the type
of guy yeah but that but what the [ __ ]
was that
and then I listened to it and I kind of
liked it but I hated that oh we all part
of it really annoyed me oh my god that's
why I never downloaded this [ __ ] but
then on the side they had a LL Cool J
big old but you know I play drums that
Michael let me hear what this track
sounds like and I put it on and he
basically teaches you how to break up
with a girl in that song but that rap
oh that that rhyme what however you
supposed to say it he breaks it down and
just in like [ __ ] 11 seconds he sits
his girls down he's basically hanging
out in like some sunglass hut for some
[ __ ] and some girl comes in with an
insane ass and he does what every guy
does he stares out any thinks I want to
[ __ ] that but oh [ __ ] I have a
girlfriend so what does he do does he
sneak around on earth now he goes home
and he sits her down he says listen I
met this girl named Tina
okay Tina's got a big old butt I know
that I said I'd be true really whiten
this up but Tina got a big old butt so
I'm leaving you it's I mean that's just
[ __ ] airtight you can't [ __ ] with
that he was 100 percent I don't know she
could get mad I think that's that I
think women so expect guys to be lying
weaselly pieces of [ __ ] that if you
actually hit him with that level of
honesty I think they would just be
stunned
just like the chick in the video like I
didn't think that that was bad acting I
think that they would absolutely be
stunned if you just came home and say
listen I met this girl I know that I
said be faithful to you but she's better
looking than you so I'm breaking up with
you
well what is the comeback there's
nothing maybe like if your girl came
home and said listen I know we're
together but this guy you know I met him
at the mall his dick is twice the size
of yours and he's got a better car so
it's kind of a no-brainer I'm out of
here
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do with your little dick and your
[ __ ] Domino's Pizza it's over you
just gotta [ __ ] be like you know you
only go around once so uh yeah I I I get
it so anyway so if you don't have time
to email al Madrigal which you should
which you should just listen to LL Cool
J big old buddy you gotta see his face
with me cuz so I'm leaving you it's it's
I don't can't explain it it's way meaner
than it has to be that's what it makes
it's funny because there's a way to read
that will you kind of letting them down
easily you know
but he didn't he just did it like yeah
this is how it works so there you go
look at that on a holiday as you shaking
off you [ __ ] Keystone lights that you
drank for the troops you know your
[ __ ] bong hits for the men and women
in the Marine Corps that you took right
Flag Day is coming up everybody
well we respect and honor all the flags
of the world come on down and get your
Bush lights oh [ __ ] in $12 a [ __ ]
case what the [ __ ] would have what would
the world be like if there was no way to
get [ __ ] up if you couldn't get high
couldn't get drunk Jesus how long would
marriages last then they'd probably be
even shorter would they just be rage
just sitting around [ __ ] up stone
sober eating strawberry shortcake could
be horrific anyways this is the Monday
morning podcast it is the end of May
everybody all right now many days are in
May 30 days heads September as soon as
April in November all the rest have a
bunch of other dates except for February
go [ __ ] yourself with your song um so I
got thirty thirty-one [ __ ] what is it
April has 30 June has 30 May's 31 well
with I got the little thing I can click
right here I have a computer I don't
need to think right it has why is it in
September Oh for chrissake do I have to
click another button it has 31 days all
right so you until have and you guys
have until Thursday midnight to make
something of May 2012 all right are you
in a [ __ ] relationship you don't want
to be in do you want to be in this
relationship you don't want to be in in
June why don't you celebrate the end of
May by getting out of your [ __ ]
relationship and sitting down and
basically
go with the LL Cool J vibe hold their
hand and just go straight honesty and
then what what's she gonna do but what's
he gonna do if they're gonna flip the
[ __ ] out but the die has been cast the
ship has set sail the ball is already
rolling the Sun is setting the rain is
falling whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call it it's out there just put it out
there let him scream and yell and in
your head as much as it sucks you're
gonna be like okay I did it I did it now
I just got to sit there and get yelled
at and how long can somebody really yell
before they lose their voice an hour 90
minutes and an hour and a half I'm gonna
be in the car listening to LL Cool J
driving away from that thing I didn't
want to be in all right now I know I
talk about this [ __ ] a lot but I think a
lot of people are in situations like
this they don't know how to sit somebody
dumb they just say so I'm leaving you
you know if I was LL Cool J and I
stopped you know selling tickets and all
that type of [ __ ] that would be a side
business that I would have I would take
that little [ __ ] rhyme that he had
and I would custom do it for everybody
in their life and just then people who
just right you all right I need to
charge it you charge him 100 bucks and
he would write you a you know four bars
it all rhymes and you just get out
exactly what you say it you know just be
like you eat with your mouth open
I know I said that I'd be true but you
eat with your mouth open so I'm leaving
you just get right you just get right
down to it your mom is a [ __ ] [ __ ] I
know I said that I'd be true but she's
[ __ ] always coming over here and
something rhymes with [ __ ] you know I
got you got the idea right Jesus Christ
what do I have to be yellow
hang on a second what the [ __ ] just
happened did I knock this out all right
ten minutes in look at that that was an
easy ten that was a [ __ ] easy ten I
actually uh actually bought a yeah I
bought a new grill I don't get a grill
you know what I bought I bought that
[ __ ] egg thing the big ceramic girls
got giant [ __ ] avocado what sucks is I
can't talk about the [ __ ] that I bought
because I feel like now it feels like
it's a commercial on this thing they're
not paying me to advertise so what so I
feel now you can't talk about them see
what happens it's a catch-22 speaking of
looking like a giant avocado how about
those Boston Celtics
what up Philly how would you think did
you really think that that was gonna
happen again that you were gonna go into
Boston for a game seven on the [ __ ]
parquet and that and that that that
wasn't gonna happen I almost went
parquet butter at that point if I ever
made that joke you guys should have just
[ __ ] just what he would unsubscribe
I'm subscribed how they say it um
Celtics beat Philly I actually watched
most of the game and then I had to go do
my gig over at flappers so I had to
listen to the rest on on the radio as I
went over there I got to tell you
something you know I'm not expecting the
Celtics to win the championship I know
we're old you know but the officiating
in the [ __ ] NBA I don't think in any
other sport I swear to God to do the
refs just dictate the [ __ ] pace and
all that and I know that I've had a
[ __ ] tampon in my ass about this for
a long time but it's ridiculous Paul let
me ask you a question would it in the
ever in any game ever forget about a
game seven of an NBA playoff to go to
the Conference Finals let's just say a
regular-season game in the middle of
[ __ ] December does Kobe Bryant ever
get called for uh does he ever foul out
on a [ __ ] charge is that call ever
going to be made against
guy I'm gonna go with never right
Paul Pierce got five files ticky-tack
file they file the guy out on a [ __ ]
charge it's
un-fuckin'-believable and just three
days before I watch Hobie I watch Kobe
[ __ ] hack a guy across both forearms
but that would have been his third foul
in the second quarter and they would
have had to sit the guy and what do they
do they have a meeting the rf7 meeting
and they give it to some bum standing
next to him it's just [ __ ] it's you
tell me the difference between the NBA
officiating and the officiating and
[ __ ] wrestling okay if you can do
that then Jesus Christ sorry did I just
lose you guys on that one
why don't you set the [ __ ] recorder
where it's supposed to be they're right
down on the floor let's just bring
everything down here there we go bill
seriously if you can do that I will
[ __ ] I will go to your town and I
will do karaoke and I'll sing whatever
song you want me to sing I'll do that LL
Cool J song and I'll white it up I know
that I said that I would be true that's
what that's what kills me about the NBA
okay I [ __ ] have really been watching
it because of the hangover and a
devastation of seeing the Bruins get
knocked out and I got into it again it's
just like basketball is a [ __ ]
phenomenal game it's a pure game you
know [ __ ] ball in a hoop loving it if
those [ __ ] striped [ __ ] would just
get out of the way and stop taking out
their [ __ ] frustration that there's
some 23 year old kid who's getting more
[ __ ] and it's worth millions of more
dollars than you and your [ __ ]
footlocker outfit so now you got to go
around and just [ __ ] dick - yeah I
have power I'm gonna do what I want to
do I don't know if it's that [ __ ] or if
it's [ __ ] David Stern in their ear
with the Bluetooth whatever whatever so
hey New Jersey's own Paul virzi he's
been talking a lot of trash you know
talking about Oklahoma City you know
it's so who's that's
he's pickin and I actually picked the
Spurs you know cuz my whole theory that
the Spurs play they play basketball the
way your dad fights you know and I think
that that was evident in last night's
game
you know Oklahoma came out all [ __ ]
you know all young full of piss and
vinegar running up and down the court
and what are they did you sort of jogged
after I'm alright yeah keep running keep
robes like that in that movie colors
that dead that straight joke with a
palpable and the in his son the son both
[Music]
father and son Bulls standing on the
hill they're looking down at a bunch of
cows and the son goes a hey let's run
down the hill and go [ __ ] one of those
cows and the dad goes now let's walk
down and [ __ ] them all all right that's
the Spurs let's walk down pick-and-roll
and [ __ ] them all
that's what they're gonna do all the way
to another NBA championship and they're
still not going to get respect because
they play in a city that nobody cares
about okay Mexicans don't even care
about San Antonio they don't all right
that's just a little stop off that they
have when they cross the border before
they go to like [ __ ] I don't know El
Paso all right it was a bad that was a
bad example El Paso I should have said
what early --gel immigrants usually end
up Denver come right up through
Albuquerque through Santa Fe you know
run past Columbine and they go right
into Denver don't they
what is that set to 35 North or is that
now if the 35 goes to Austin there's how
much [ __ ] Road try road drive and
road travel and I've done it goes to ten
is the eight and there's the ten and
there's a forty and there's the 70 then
there's the 80 then there's the 90
that's going east west
those are evens odds go north south
I [ __ ] I can't [ __ ] remember anymore
that gives a [ __ ] anyways so what do you
guys think when the Celtics limp through
another round can they beat I like how
they act like because Chris Bosh is out
of it like they don't still have LeBron
James and that guy with the little mouth
what's Dwyane Wade what is with his fish
lips I don't understand he looks like a
[ __ ] tuna that can dunk um all right
what did I [ __ ] am i right now I know I
got I got to do some advertising sorry
people I'm doing like you know one of
these days I'm actually getting no I'm
not gonna lie to you I was gonna say you
know one of these days I'm gonna get
this thing into a studio and you know
there's gonna be the guy the the [ __ ]
Baba Booey guy who comes in or the
[ __ ] this guy it's not happening all
right it isn't this is what it is all
right just like a CD C's first album
okay do you think that they were gonna
do something else no this is what we're
doing three chords kick you in the [ __ ]
and a guitar solo and that's it go [ __ ]
yourself we're done until the next one
comes out that's what I'm doing with
this all right I don't have time
yes I do I have I of the time are I'm
lazy
all right well [ __ ] you you push it off
in your life don't you all right here's
one for you the man great everybody and
I just received my first man great they
just sent me a free one this Father's
Day there's only one perfect gift you
guys all grilled this weekend eye on
your little hibachis with those anorexic
little greats that you have and all the
grease drips down and likes your Egg
McMuffin on fire isn't that annoying you
know because that's one of the things
you really you get judged as a guy you
know I mean what your woman looks like
what kind of car you drive and then your
skills on the grill okay that's how you
judge and I'm sure that this will be
made fun of someday on a show like The
Office they will somehow try
and just they'll show a guy who's good
on the grill right and then somehow they
say but you know underneath he has he
has an underlying insecurity right
because no one can just be the [ __ ]
man anymore
the man great everybody this is the deal
it's a grill enhancement system you
don't have to go buy a new grill
do you already have a grill are you
nodding your head yes
all right wouldn't you like to [ __ ]
put a supercharger on it
that's what the man grade is all right
oh the next line what is a man great us
man greats are 100% made in America
cast-iron grilling grates all right see
given Americans jobs and you're grilling
good lord all we need is a stripper in
here and we've done an American flag
this this is you have a Kid Rock video
um these heavy-duty grilling grates
deliver exactly what you need to achieve
the steakhouse flavor you've been
looking for now what they're really
saying there is are you tired of your
friends making fun of you and your
lame-ass cube steaks this is gonna teach
you how to grill correctly or at least
you know what I'm trying to say with man
grates patented design chicken steak or
veggies for all the trader Joe people
veggies will have never tasted so good
no more flip flare-ups no more dry meat
guaranteed
they guarantee it so basically they're
giving you something that will make it
impossible for you to mess up mess it up
which means as you're growing you can be
looking over your shoulder talking trash
to your friends about how good your
burgers are gonna be all right take
advantage of their $20 Monday morning
podcast special today by clicking on the
man great banner at billboard.com all
you do is you go to billboard.com you
click on the podcast page you look over
to the right all right you look over to
the right you click on the man great
banner and as a bonus every
billboard.com order comes with a heavy
duty man great grilling brush to clean
it up with all right they're made in
America they're 100% cast iron
you'll get steak house quality grilling
in your backyard
20 bucks off because of my spike podcast
and you're a listener just go to the man
Greg banner on the podcast page at
billboard.com there you go get some for
your father
you know your dad grill of course he
does probably fought for this country
too
the last generation of real men alright
let's get back to the podcast where the
hell is it alright let's get back to the
stuff here you know lately I've been
asking I've been asking some of the
ladies to write in and finally I haven't
even read this yet but this already
seems like gold this is this is the the
Anna subject line of this email it says
I think the guy I'm dating is a [ __ ]
hello bill I am a 21 year old student I
began listening to your podcast recently
and I heard you complaining about how
women have not written in in a while and
being a woman myself decided to do so
and ask you for advice well god bless
you I live at home with my mom and go to
college I recently found a very nice guy
there at college and was really into him
but then I started suspecting something
strange I started suspecting that maybe
he was a [ __ ] at first I thought it was
pretty harmless but then one night we
had a house party and everyone was
pretty drunk and a friend of mine who I
haven't seen in a while was there and
when everyone was way way way past drunk
she tried to get into a fight with me
and eventually pushed me down the wall
then stole my iPhone and he was there
and did nothing Jesus Christ I was so
scared that I called my ex to come get
me and he did Wow I you think you're
dating a [ __ ] I mean that right there
gee and he just stood there and let this
other guy who used to hook up with you
come in riding in on his white horse
anyways my ex was more of a man than the
guy I was dating now even though the guy
I'm dating was drunk I felt like he
should have protected me or done
something anything he did nothing and
later he even confessed to me that he
was scared of
drunk friend and even scared of me what
the [ __ ] right even though he says this
will never happen again I have enough
knowledge to know that people do do not
usually change like that you know that's
really wise that you're really wise for
your age at 21 if you if you're already
not buying into the I'm gonna change
that's your you're wise beyond your
years you know they say that you're
basically your psychological makeup is
done by the time you 3 so if you see
some little toddler standing there while
somebody's taking his blocks that kid's
gonna be a [ __ ] anyway so should I be
upset
or give him another chance is this a
deal breaker is there no way to change a
guy from a [ __ ] to a real man should I
just break things off with him and if so
should I remain friends with him thanks
Bill I hope you read this I love you in
the oh that's nice all right this is the
deal you asking a question is there no
way to change a guy from a [ __ ] to a
real man no I don't think I think that
that happens I think it happens way more
in movies where somebody has a
life-changing moment and then they just
decide I'm not going to take [ __ ]
anymore
but even then that just begins the
journey of not being a [ __ ] you don't
just say I'm not gonna be a [ __ ] then
BAM you're not a [ __ ] anymore you have
to you got to work your way up it's like
if you were a hundred pounds overweight
and you're like this I'm done I'm not
eating [ __ ] ice cream anymore the
next day you don't have a six-pack you
know takes a [ __ ] year or something
you really got to turn it around so um I
don't know what are you looking for in a
guy I mean I I think the fact that
you're writing me and you're saying I
think the guy I'm dating is a [ __ ] I
mean that that actually hurts me on some
level just because I insert myself into
this story and the person I'm dating
would be calling me a [ __ ] or it could
it be the ex I guess
I don't know this isn't about me it's
about you come on bill stop being
selfish all right um I think you've
totally lost less respect for this guy
and if you don't respect the person
you're with eventually you're gonna blow
somebody else you know if you don't
break up with this guy that's what I'm
predicting if you don't break up with
this guy you're just gonna cheat on them
just to facilitate getting out of the
relationship because you know to get to
that LL Cool J moment we can just be
[ __ ] honest but I don't think you
like that I've been something about you
knowing that people don't change at your
age and the fact he like you know this
guy's a [ __ ] he's not sticking up for
me and the fact that he didn't stick up
for you and then you took charge and say
well I'm gonna [ __ ] call somebody who
will I mean technically you should have
[ __ ] your ex-boyfriend that night and
he and he shouldn't have been mad he
should have been like and he probably
would have been because he's a [ __ ] I
know I understand I mean you know when
you needed a big swing and dick I mean
God knows it wasn't me so yeah um I
think if you don't break up with this
guy you're actually fighting nature all
right and you guys are wired to - I know
you guys aren't wired to just have kids
with [ __ ]
you know I mean you want a strong son
right you know what you know what that
[ __ ] DNA and your kid right oh that's
gonna kill you imagine that you have a
kid with this guy and you want this kid
to be like like your ex-boyfriend and it
comes out and it's like this [ __ ]
little wormy worm guy
ah it'll be awful walking down the aisle
to marry this guy with that sheepish
deserve you know what Dad you want this
guy to be the man standing down there
and a white tuxedo like [ __ ] Roger
Moore and James Bond I think I think
look I don't know if this just happened
and you're really upset so you know in
like in three days you're not gonna care
and you're gonna go back to having a
picnic with this guy because for all I
know your ex who came coming back maybe
you broke up with him because he cheated
on
you maybe he was too much of a guy if
you know what I mean so then you said
well all right I'm gonna maybe I'm this
next time I'm dating a nice guy so now
you dated a nice guy the thing about is
sometimes you date a nice guy they can
be so nice that they're [ __ ] all
right and look I'm not ki I'm not
sitting here acting like you know if I'm
out with my girl in some [ __ ] 200
pound 300 pound jacked [ __ ] 25 year
old comes up and starts doing [ __ ] then
I'm gonna start swinging because I'm not
I'm not I'm not getting my [ __ ] a
head kicked in just for the [ __ ] of it
no you know what I mean I mean it's not
like just you know straight across the
board as a guy you have to [ __ ] go
and get you a goddamn head kicked in but
this was a [ __ ] woman this was a lady
I mean he Jesus it's that it is a weird
situation in defense of him where how do
you get the [ __ ] iPhone back you
start wrestling with her now you kind of
[ __ ] throwing a girl around so you're
looking at that possible assault charge
because god knows that's how the world
worked works right now Your Honor I was
trying to steal a phone and he that this
guy assaulted me and you're gonna be
sent alone she was stealing a phone and
they're not gonna be able to get past
your you're a guy and she's a girl but
you know he should've just he should
have just held her by the back of her
pants so she couldn't leave and just
stayed out of reach of her swinging
that's what you do if you're in that
situation as a guy you just reached out
you grabbed by the back of their pants
and you just start running in a circle
until cops get there so they can't swing
at you they're running backwards I mean
I don't know what you gotta you gotta
[ __ ] do something and he didn't do
anything that's the big thing if you
told me honestly if he told me that this
was some giant guy who could kick the
[ __ ] out of him I wouldn't say that the
guy's a [ __ ] you know what I mean I
mean what is the point of going in and
getting a concussion getting your tooth
driven up through your [ __ ] nose the
guy's still going to leave with your
phone
you know let's said old richard pryor
bit macho man and i'll take that knife
and stick it up your ass macho man it's
like no you're gonna get the [ __ ] kicked
out of you but this was a woman
alright pill for fucksakes quit you have
goddamn ramblin wrap it up i think you
know what you want to do when you should
do it you are dating a [ __ ] the fact
that when he was sober he said that he
was scared of her and of you he seems
like he's a little for klimt and I just
can't imagine there's gonna be a
stereotype but a guy like that actually
putting it on you in the bedroom
I really don't he probably stares at you
and yeah am i hurting you is everything
okay
god you're so beautiful I mean come on
alright flip her over push your face in
the pillows always she says in PS don't
worry that [ __ ] I used to call a friend
who pushed me and took my phone is no
longer in my life did you get your phone
back what happened with you guys
now wait a minute what like them can I
hear the follow-up here there's so many
different ways this could be going was
that like a girl like when you thought
that maybe you were swinging another way
and all of a sudden you broke up with
her and uh probably not it's just my own
red shoe diary kind of [ __ ] thing
so anyways um what are we 30 minutes in
in the Monday morning podcast I got it I
got to give a little shout-out here to a
flappers comedy club in Burbank
California the city that Johnny Carson
made famous
I had a [ __ ] unbelievably great time
this weekend
I did four shows out there Friday
Saturday night
it's the perfect sized club they
couldn't have been more friendly that
the all the shows were packed I was
working out my new hour and it was great
I was working with the chelsea peretti
Sacramento's own chelsea peretti she was
hella funny as they say up there yeah
she was [ __ ] great she sang some rib
Nicholas line about Michael Bolton
backstage like just [ __ ] around and I
said to her you got to do that on stage
you got to do that on stage right so
most people go I can't do it you think
you came up with it I'm looking to do
she went up and she did it and closed
with it and it was just one of those one
of those weekends it just I don't know
you'd have to be a comedian to
understand how much that like gets you
going to be like alright I'm gonna go up
and go try some [ __ ] if she's just gonna
go [ __ ] sing some [ __ ] up a lot in
line about Michael Bolton what I'm gonna
go up there and [ __ ] out of my jokes
mother knew things that I want to try so
I was psyched I feel like I already got
I have a solid 25 minutes towards my new
hour where I can actually you know run
my mouth and not do anything on the
special that's coming up because that's
basically the game you take the special
the second it's done you then have from
whenever you finish taping to when the
new one comes out to somehow come up
with an hour of [ __ ] that you can say to
a crowd and they won't demand their
money back so I have until October and I
figure I feel like I'm already halfway
there you know this time next week I'm
actually gonna go out with the buddy of
mine you know I never wrote a motorcycle
my life he's gonna teach me how to do it
I know what you guys are thinking
motorcycle Oh [ __ ] just go buy the
coffin with it I'm not about dirt bikes
I'm just gonna ride it [ __ ] dirt bike
just cuz I want to learn how to [ __ ]
ride one you know what I mean just for
that MacGyver moment this - there's a
couple things I want to learn how to do
I want to [ __ ] learn how to ride a
motorcycle and maybe fly a helicopter
just so I have my you know just in case
if I'm ever in some Jason Bourne kind of
situation you ever think about that [ __ ]
was great about actions [ __ ] heroes
is I don't give a [ __ ] what vehicle it
is I don't care if it can fly if it's on
the water if it's a [ __ ] dump truck
if it's a god
damn tank itself is a [ __ ] hovercraft
those sons of [ __ ] not only did they
have time to be trained in every form of
martial arts swords weaponry guns
anything they know how all that works
and they can drive every [ __ ] vehicle
known to man you know you got to do that
you got it as a guy you got to make your
or a woman alright as a girl remember
that we need to spell it grrl cuz you
guys want taking no mush you got to make
that [ __ ] your your action hero list
you know your Jason Bourne list have you
ever seen an action movie where the
[ __ ] guy jumps into some vehicle a
plane or anything is like I just how
does this work does anybody know how to
drive a [ __ ] helicopter fly it or
whatever I want to be able to do that
[ __ ] you know what's-his-face Tom Cruise
Tom Cruise has a pilot's licence he can
ride a motorcycle remember Top Gun when
he was [ __ ] riding with without his
helmet on right he can ride him he can
drive a sports car I wanted at the
helicopter though that's probably the
wild card everybody's got that it's like
a great picture he's got he's got his
four pitches or whatever but not
everybody has to cut fastball I think
the helicopter is the cut fastball for a
maybe it's a knuckleball for an action
hero whatever whatever I never learned
how to ride a motorcycle because my
parents would not allow it they just
wouldn't allow it and you know the [ __ ]
was I gonna do I didn't have the money
to buy one I wanted to get one which
required them I was like can you buy me
this they're like no any we could afford
it we wouldn't I was like why not
they're like cuz you're gonna [ __ ]
die alright and this is annoying as you
are as a child we don't want that to
happen so no we're not we're not getting
you that and then I remember I got old
enough and I was gonna buy the
motorcycle came out it was called the
Honda rebel and it was only 1,200 bucks
this was the 80s and I still remember
the
commercial you something like look at my
wall she was 951 so I called up my girl
and said let's have some fun and we
rolled riding on a rebel baby died my
boo did leave let me get this [ __ ]
bike something like that right and I was
gonna buy it and the girl I was seeing
at the time said if you buy that you
might as well buy the coffin to go with
it
and I don't know I talked to a couple
other people and people work in
emergency rooms they call people who
ride motorcycles they just call them
organ donors and and I was under the
impression of yeah but what if you got
really good at riding a bike you know
people suck at riding bikes maybe if you
got really good at it and I basically
eventually probably somebody told me
it's like listening stupid it doesn't
matter how good you are if somebody
sucks at driving a car they're in a
[ __ ] car you're on a motorcycle
that's it you know there's no fender
benders as they say on those things so I
was just like all right you know what
that's probably a good idea
oh [ __ ] action heroes can also ride a
horse
it's just nothing kid there's nothing
they can't [ __ ] do then climb up the
side of a building so what you gotta do
you got to get a chin-up bar and then
you got to start knocking down all these
modes of transportation cuz that's
that's as big a part of [ __ ]
Armageddon as you know growing your own
food and having your own water supply
you have to be able to drive every mode
of transportation I guaran-fucking-tee
you if you go on YouTube there's gonna
be a video I've never looked this up but
how to drive a tank
I bet somewhere on the inner hand the
somewhere on the Internet I bet that
there's a video that will teach you how
to do that [ __ ] so anyways what the hell
was I talking about I just totally lost
my goddamn train of thought oh yeah so
I'm gonna be off - I know what I'm
talking about coming up with this new
our material so how I do it this is how
I do it is obviously I throw out all my
[ __ ] man I only go back to the old hour
if I have to and I just keep talking new
[ __ ]
I take all rules of hack I throw them
out the window I will just I will and
right down to a Michael Jackson
impression if I could do it I would do
it on stage I wouldn't give a [ __ ] and
I'm just just to be saying something new
that'll just get me thinking that way
and then in my personal life I go out
and I try and do some [ __ ] that I never
did before because I know goddamn well
I'm gonna make an ass of myself trying
to ride that bike I'll stall it out I'll
do a faceplant I'll do something [ __ ]
stupid or whatever uh I mean even that
[ __ ] [ __ ] I just said there about the
[ __ ] Action Hero so they can drive
something something will come out of it
so that is my that is what I'm going to
be working on coming up and I got a
bunch of actually stand-up gigs it
starts to get crazy again in in June I'm
gonna be at the San Jose Improv chelsea
peretti is on that one also I had to
give her that one it's so close to her
hometown of Sacramento all her peeps are
going to come down be hella excited
that's on June 15th and 16th and then
I'm doing the aunt and on the 17th I'm
at the Chicago theater and that's a
Vince Vaughn show Vince Vaughn Wild West
Show it's gonna be me
obviously Vince Vaughn Steve Byrne I got
to get you guys in that lineup that's
gonna be insane and the Chicago theater
is the [ __ ] I actually got to work at
one time previously when I was working
with the great Jimmy Norton on his tour
the antisocial tour was me Norton at L
in Breuer that was such an unbelievable
show and the Bruins won the Stanley Cup
that night so this is my triumphant
return to the Chicago theater that's
going to be Sunday June 17th all right
so are you mustachioed stereotypical
Chicago people bring [ __ ] 6000 TV
closest friends down to that kick and
Ontario improv the Inland Empire June
29th 30
in July first and then the next gig I
got after that is Hampton Beach in New
Hampshire on July 14th in Newport Rhode
Island I'm doing the Newport yachting
center which sounds really like I said
snooty but it's a tent that they put up
in the parking lot
in Newport Rhode Island July 15th and
that's actually one of my favorite gigs
because I get to go back and see all
kinds of friends and family and that's
it and by then I'm guarantee you by that
July 15th I'm gonna have my 45 [ __ ]
minutes down that's my goal by July 15th
to have a new 45 minutes and then I can
coast through you know August and
September get that next 15 and then my
special comes out right and hopefully
everybody likes it then they come out to
see me nobody's like oh he's got a whole
new [ __ ] hour and that is how you do
it
all right dilemma bill would you rather
lose your drivers drivers license
forever or spend the rest of your life
as a vegan oh man that is a great one
and I obviously can't cheat on the diet
what a hell of a dilemma drive around is
a grumpy skinny douche for the rest of
my life no no no no wait yeah wait would
you right I just got lost in that lose
your driver's license forever or spend
the rest of your license oh I'd have to
walk around is a meat-eating jackass
spend the rest of my life as a vegan I
I'd have to be a vegan I'd have to be a
vegan what am I going to think I just
sit around eating burgers walking around
the block
asking people to drive me places I
wonder if you could get used to that
though I lost my license for drinking
and driving a long time ago and that was
back when you only lost it for 45 days
on a first offense and they didn't count
the first two weeks while I was waiting
to get arraigned so it was probably more
like 45 I probably lost it for I don't
think was two weeks either I lost if
like 50 something days and I remember
towards the end of it I almost I forgot
what it was like to drive just after
that amount of time you know if I lost
my driver's license forever I would just
live I would live in New York City
that's what I would do
hey you know I'd be like one of those
[ __ ] people you know you live in New
York Jesus Christ New York City man why
you know what the smartest thing ever I
left New York City at 39 that was the
smartest thing I ever did New York City
is such a city for young people you know
I know I've said this [ __ ] before but
like if you this is thing I really feel
that you got to live there at some point
your life it's [ __ ] awesome you have
to live there but don't stay there too
long you stay there too long there's
just something happens you become a
agoraphobic you know you have some
unhealthy relationship with the [ __ ]
animal and I'm not saying bestiality but
like you know instead of having a kid
you have like a cat and all you do is
sit around bitching that there's no
[ __ ] good restaurants in your
neighborhood and it's just it just you
get all hunched over you start looking
like you have osteoporosis even if you
don't this that that city is for young
people and go there have a good time and
then you got to get out don't hang that
too long because you end up
it's like Matthew McConaughey in Dazed
and Confused you're just hanging around
and it's it's not a good thing oh and
speaking of which how about the New
Jersey Devils the New Jersey Devils in
the LA Kings who do you like who do you
like and the Rangers lose
the Rangers lose my condolences to all
Rangers fans and my condolences to the
world's most famous arena slash food
court once again another year goes by no
NBA title no Stanley Cup but for some
reason it's the world's most famous
arena because of music because of
Frankie Sinatra because of Led Zeppelin
because of Muhammad Ali not because of
the ranges of the Knicks okay and I know
that's a bitter pill for you New York
sports fans to swallow and that's
exactly why I'm handing it to you on a
nice [ __ ] pillow swallow it because
it's all you
Celtics by the way are still in it going
for their 18th NBA World Championship
all Championships born in the NBA in the
National Basketball Association as
opposed to that other team out west that
counts that BA a title we won an NBA
title before there was even an NBA
anyways by the way I got to give the
Rangers props though to Ranger fans
everybody's stole your let's go Rangers
everybody stole that from you guys in
1994 you guys were the only guys doing
it it became [ __ ] iconic and now
everybody does it you know
let's go Bruins no one ever did that it
was here we go we go that's what the
[ __ ] it was now here people go let's go
Bruins and it bugs me I actually looked
up the history of the beat LA chant and
because some jackass was trying to be
like [ __ ] the San Francisco giant fan
you should show you that to the Dodgers
back in this chick gal go [ __ ] yourself
no they didn't all right according to my
[ __ ] internet research the history of
the beat LA chant was actually when the
76ers beat the Celtics in Game seven in
1982 and they were going and we hated
the [ __ ] Lakers that's how much we
hated the Lakers to sell the 76ers
beat us in our own goddamn building we
knew it was over and the fans chanted
beat la actually they chanted it to the
76ers alright that's how much we [ __ ]
hated la you know we weren't going [ __ ]
you 76ers yada-yada-yada all that
[ __ ] we were just like alright you
beat us you know as much as we [ __ ]
hate that we hate the Lakers more and
then the beat la chant was born all
right and if that isn't a [ __ ]
phenomenal story I don't know what is
and I got to tell you something I hated
the 76ers back then but when I look back
and I remember those teams I [ __ ] I love
him now Maurice Cheeks Andrew Tony Bobby
Jones dr. J oh and then when they
brought in Moses Malone it was just
phenomenal and I love their uniforms
back then I don't know why they just
don't go back to those I don't know why
every [ __ ] uniform has to be so
goddamn disco DUP I just don't get it
they were just simple back then I don't
know although I got to say I like the
new Atlanta Hawks uniforms I like those
better though than ones they had back in
a day during Dominique's they were they
would definitely I don't know what the
[ __ ] was going on with that all right
please beat the dead horse bill you've
received this email a million times all
right can you please beat the dead horse
and make make it clear one more time
that she should not be wasting any more
time with him anymore
sincerely pronouns what I don't even get
that I know you're trashing me can you
please beat the dead horse and make it
clear one more time that she should not
be wasting any more time with him
anymore I know what the [ __ ] that is you
got me you got me serf or ma'am or
whatever you beat me I don't even know
what that means weird signals from a
sort of a creepy friend hey Bill I'm a
girl that has a lot of guy friends
I'd say about 70% of my friends are guys
half are gay half aren't
you know what I can't [ __ ] stand I
hate women who have gay friends and they
referred him well that's my gay
he's my gay I [ __ ] up those women are
the [ __ ] worst
and then this stupid gay friend comes
around cock-blocking yeah you know with
his sassy [ __ ] [ __ ] coming in and
out that's what he just like why don't
the two you go [ __ ] fingerblast each
other now it's really it's really
[ __ ] annoying it's really annoying
it's and then I always feel like the gay
guy is gay in it up is actively just
like acting extra gay like sitcom gay
not like real-life gay and this is the
whole [ __ ] thing it's just annoying
so anyways she goes and lately I've been
noticing a lot of my male friends have
started staring at me it's a little
weird because I've known them for a
while and no one ever looked at me twice
but over the last two months I keep
catching them looking particularly my
friend so-and-so all right well what's
going on with you did you hit the gym
will you late developing are you
dressing differently so what so is my
age and sort and sort of kind of has a
girlfriend but not really oh Jesus
are you that kind of girl Nia went off
on back in the day girl has all guy
friends anyways she just turned 15 oh
wait a minute I you underaged I don't
wanna read this she just turned 15 and
he's determined to wait around for two
years until she's legal in the eyes of
the state we live in to officially date
and get with her since all they've done
is kiss creepy I think yes I would say
definitely yes if you sitting there
floating around just going let me tell
you something man
the second the law allows me to take my
dick out I'm gonna do it that's [ __ ]
creepy
anyways now even though he's allegedly
in love with this child he gets super
flirty with me when we hang up even
going so far as to cop feels make jokes
about us hooking up and give me long
hugs yet stay away from this guy this
guy's a creep she goes I'm friends with
this dude but this whole situation
weirds me out as it should
I'm not sure if he really wants to stay
with his girlfriend or try to get or try
his hand at dating someone
age-appropriate but there's a [ __ ]
ton of mixed signals going on here and
any outside insight would be awesome
thanks in advance I think you got to go
with you gut on this one I think the
reason why you're getting creeped out is
because this guy's creepy that's [ __ ]
creepy
this [ __ ] creepy alright a 22 year
old guy with the 15 that's Chris Hansen
can you eat can you kiss a girl who's 15
at 22 what are you doing you're in the
prime of your life there's plenty of
[ __ ] you're 22 years old that's it
you're a [ __ ] rock star there's a
zillion women that you could get with
yeah this guy is a creep he's beyond a
[ __ ] creep I remember when I was
twenty to one eighteen-year-old girl
felt like a child at that point it was
just weed like that that's a huge jump
they're still living at home
you know you're of legal drinking age
you're going to titty bars you're
getting arrested for [ __ ] drinking
and driving you flunked out of college I
mean you're eons away from where they
they were at eight years how I felt I
remember as a senior in college like
freshmen seemed like like children
that's [ __ ] weird yeah I would stay
away from that guy and and as far as
guys looking at you it sounds like
you're uh
you have to turn into a swan there cutie
pie so why don't you go get a guy you
deserve stay away from the future sex
offender you know because you're just
gonna have to testify in his trial
because your friends
that he's actually a good guy rather
than a bad guy that is beyond [ __ ] up
a 22 year old guy making out with a 15
year old girl tis beyond [ __ ] up
that's beyond [ __ ] up all right that's
like to the point I wish I didn't even
read it they're like ruins takes all the
[ __ ] comedy out of this [ __ ] all
right 53 minutes in what do we got to do
it hey how about some advertising that's
a nice setup huh a little Chris Hanson
story and now let me tell you some stuff
you got to buy all right what do we got
here stamps calm everybody you know what
I've been talking about it forever I've
been using it now for like what since
like February shipping all of my DVDs in
my BVDs in my own apartment dead serious
man I got it I got the scale
I still haven't bought my little I'm a
postman hat yet you know a little visor
like is he gonna ship a package or win
the US Open nobody knows
look there's few things that are a
bigger waste of time they going to the
post office when something like
stamps.com exists all right you can
basically bring the post office into
your house you can print legal stamps
all right right off their website right
out of your printer right onto your
envelope or onto a box you got a little
scale if you need like whatever you call
that one the postage I guess you can you
can do the whole thing you can do
everything that you can do at the post
office
except waste time in your life all right
stamps calm will not only save your time
you can buy and print out like I just
said the official US postage on your
computer or printer you can print exact
postage on any other pocket package
right from your desk stamps com will
also save your money it's a fraction of
the cost of a postage meter plus you get
discounts you can't even find at the
post office right now if use my last
name ber b you are r for this special
offer you get a no risk trial plus $110
bonus offer that includes a digital
scale and up to 55 $3 in postage alright
don't wait go to stamps calm now before
you do anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in ber be u RR that
stamps.com and enter Barbie urr and also
I have other exciting news if that
wasn't exciting enough that you can
bring this the post office into your
apartment would it be great if you can
bring the titty bar into your apartment
are you sick of going there and paying
those high ATM fees for a woman who's
not gonna bang you would it be nice if
somebody came and shook their titties
right in your own apartment
titties calm I was telling you guys how
if you go to amazon.com through my
website on the podcast page you just
click on it and if you're gonna buy
something you just buy it that way you
know if they do anything else once you
get to amazon.com that they kick me back
some money and 10% of the proceeds go to
the Wounded Warriors well I got my first
check from amazon.com so I I can't do it
today because they don't do that they
don't pick up the mail tomorrow I get to
write a nice check courtesy of you guys
for taking the time to go through
billboard.com go to the podcast page and
click on on the amazon banner and i want
to thank all you guys for doing that
because you know this is really perfect
Memorial Day weekend to be bringing this
up that we get to actually you know help
out the wounded warriors project through
by inflow bees on amazon.com
so I actually use it I'm rebuilding this
cabaret tur and I just go on my own damn
podcast click on that you know
rebuilding the Holly 4160 dude and I
know that that sounds impressive it
definitely has that man great vibe to it
doesn't it but I got to tell you it's
not that difficult taking it apart and
then putting it back together it really
isn't that difficult what is difficult
though is I haven't got to the part we
got to use a little measure and didn't
make sure the float is at the right
level and then adjusting the carburetors
but I gotta be honest with you I don't
think that that is gonna get is gonna be
that hard either once you've taken
something apart you don't I mean I don't
and then put it back together it's not
as scary anymore which is why surgeons
are so goddamn arrogant you know
when they cut you open and move around
your friggin overeasy your goddamn liver
and then sew you back up and you don't
die I mean do you really think that they
think they're buying the next round I
thinks you know is arrogant as
professional athletes are I think that
like surgeons should be twice as [ __ ]
arrogant really did you split the D and
dunk from the foul line I cut open a
guy's skull [ __ ] played pattycake
with his brain put it back together and
he can still talk alright
go [ __ ] yourself Kobe and then he steps
on you alright let's get back to the
podcast here where the hell is it with
the rest of the stuff here oh my god
here's one for you guys my boyfriend
wants to have his foreskin restored by
the way how fresh and new are these
these emails here just because it's
coming from the female perspective I
love this [ __ ] alright not saying I want
guys to email him but I would like to
have a nice balance here I already say
enough [ __ ] trash and women so it helps
if women come in trash and guys because
I you know it'll be a nice balance here
alright my boyfriend wants to have his
foreskin restored dear bill I wanted to
get your take on a situation I'm in with
my current boyfriend I'm a girl all
right
a few weeks ago my boyfriend of two
years told me that he's become totally
upset that he circumcised and wants to
restore his foreskin via taping and
stretching methods what and basically
why he wants to do this is because
everybody they say that intercourse you
lose like I don't know some percentage
of sensitivity when you have your
foreskin removed and all I can say is no
guy can tell the difference whether he
has a foreskin or whether he doesn't
because unless you got laid when you
were [ __ ] six weeks old you don't
know what you're gaining or what you're
missing so I don't understand why you
would do this
so buy restore his foreskin via taping
and stretching methods she goes I know I
know it makes me want to throw up
just thinking about it I wanted to tell
him I think he's out of his mind but I
don't want to hurt his feelings
the thing is I'm totally grossed out by
the idea of foreskin penises are gross
enough already
there's no need to make it even grosser
you know what am I the only guy that
totally agrees with that is there
anything more [ __ ] disgusting than a
[ __ ] flaccid foreskin cover dick I
know what it looks like it looks like a
[ __ ] I don't know what it looks like
it's just [ __ ] disgusting I don't
even have like a reference looks like an
elephant dick I don't know what just
gross it's [ __ ] disgusting she goes
obviously I can't tell him how I feel
he's clearly having a really hard time
with this he tells me that he feels
violated and disfigured
this guy's a [ __ ] this throat this
throw this guy into the [ __ ] [ __ ]
bin and get on with your life
he also claims that foreskins has a lot
of advantage for both partners but it's
hard for me to totally buy that
considering the fact I have slept with a
couple uncircumcised guy and I didn't
notice any extra pleasure although I did
use a condom with both guys yeah he's
full of [ __ ] he's full of [ __ ] it might
be more pleasure for him I don't know
what I mean I think it's amazing that
women will put a dick in their mouths
you know the at least you can do is try
and tidy up down there
you know how about happened [ __ ]
empathy I'm ass just disgust it's just
[ __ ] extra skin yeah nothing more
sexier than extra skin yeah yeah it's
like your dick used to be obese and then
lost a ton of weight but didn't having
enough money to have that surgery they
get rid of the extra that's gross
there's another two paragraphs people
just just preparing you for another two
paragraphs of having an uncircumcised
stretch tape dick in your head anyway I
think it's absolutely disgusting and
totally weird that he wants to do this
and I'm starting to get really turned
off by the idea of sleeping with him
while he's stretching out his foreskin
he told me he's going to tape it to an
elastic strap which he's going to tie
around his leg I know what the [ __ ] is
he just coming up with this [ __ ] on his
own I told him they should see a doctor
before he starts to do this but he
doesn't want but he doesn't think that
doctors know much about this sort of
thing oh so he's just gonna take it in
his own hands congratulations sweetheart
you're dating a [ __ ] [ __ ] that come
on this is the father your children
coming up with you know taking an
erector set to his [ __ ] dick it was
you do I have to finish reading this I'm
thinking of breaking it off with them
really of course you are I thought he
was a normal guy but I had no idea he
had all this freaky [ __ ] going on
underneath the surface anyways what do
you think about all of this you got to
go LL Cool J he's gonna do anything he's
stretching out you [ __ ] dick I know I
said I'd be true you're stretching out
you [ __ ] dick so I'm leaving you go
[ __ ] yourself
it's over yeah [ __ ] gross anyway what
do you think all this am i justified
dumping him away would that make me an
insensitive [ __ ] no it would make you a
strong person alright you go with you
got on this one this guy is trying to do
the impossible like like he said [ __ ]
scientists and that Michael J Fox movie
Back to the Future he's basically you
know doing the DeLorean [ __ ] with
his dick and he doesn't want to go see a
doctor any doctor would tell him you
can't do that
you'll be funny those if you dump this
guy right and it actually
and then he starts screaming like Billy
Mays on TV with his dick stretcher then
he sells it for 1995 it makes a zillion
dollar playing devil's advocate here you
know there's a 99% chance you're doing
the right thing but there is a 1% chance
you could be walking away from a
potential millionaire because I gotta be
honest with you if that guy actually
pulls this off no pun intended if he
pulls this off and he's able to do it
with some household material and then he
you know people they already make
millions of dollars with those those
pills that say they're gonna make you
dick bigger which we all know it doesn't
work because if it [ __ ] worked that
would be an international story and and
then it still wouldn't work because then
what would happen was everybody would
take big dick pills even guys with big
dicks because they don't want everybody
else catching up with them so then
having a little dick would then be like
having a six-inch dick as opposed to a
three inch 4 inch dick right does the
math work out on that or get bumped up
you've got a six seven inch dick you
just you just regular no you actually
got regular yeah you'd have a little
dick so if this guy actually [ __ ] is
able to pull this that doesn't even make
sense
he's going if he thought he was
disfigured now wait till he tries to
[ __ ] do this I mean his dick is gonna
look like you know when those people put
that [ __ ] their earlobes they put those
[ __ ] those circle circular things you
could shoot a goddamn [ __ ] bow and
arrow through somebody's earlobe and not
draw any blood he's gonna do that to his
dick except he's not gonna have that
thing in there and he's gonna be hanging
our right bill we got it it's disgusting
all right overrated underrated
underrated a steakhouse dinner with you
bullies
there's nothing better than stuffing
your fat face with your friends
devouring menu filet mignon prime rib
and porterhouse and leaving nothing on
your plate at the end
recently my two buddies and I went to
Morton's Steakhouse and we each spent
115 bucks to
byte having $100 giftcard we've got our
own steak sides shrimp cocktails to
start and drinks to keep us twisted we
ate like royalty royalty despite being
low level pieces of [ __ ] you cannot even
we could not have been that gluttonous
with the ladies why not no offense to
any wives or girlfriends but nothing
beats pigging out on quality food and
not giving a [ __ ] about how you look in
the process you and your girl just can't
do that sort of Steakhouse thing but you
can do with your boys
abso-fucking-lutely uh you know what
dude
you sound like a chick you're not gonna
pick out in front of your girl you know
what come see me in San Jose
when [ __ ] Peretti opens up for me she
actually talks about eating a lot of
women love wanna [ __ ] and throw down all
right but I know what you mean I thought
just to hang out with guys it just makes
you feel like you're running your own
corporation when you have a steak dinner
with you with just hanging out with the
guys right smoking a cigar you're
drinking a scotch and everybody feels
like they're [ __ ] you know HD
buttercup shave yeah overrated fake tits
they're too stiff that they look silly
to me and uncomfortable for her I don't
know why women keep doing this it isn't
better thank you
that's one of the truest things ever you
know they're [ __ ] they're they're
horrific and they don't feel good and I
think natural titties look better always
regardless of the size it's just it's
just not that big a deal it really isn't
that you would do that that you would
take a bag of chemicals and have it
inserted into your body it's just
[ __ ] insane
I think it was a bad idea and I think
it's over fake titties it's it's like
bell-bottoms it's over all right just
let it go it was a bad idea
underrated the natural boob both jiggly
and eco-friendly absolutely all right
that's the podcast for this week I think
I had everything I had to talk about
except I guess gamefly.com I didn't
bring that up
all you video gamers out there you guys
seen the new Grand Theft Auto that's
coming out well why don't you go to
[ __ ] gamefly.com why am i cursing why
don't you go to gamefly.com huh why
don't you where the hell is it where the
hell it man grades damn stuck um
advertising schedule here we go stay
gamefly.com everybody goto gamefly.com
slash / and you'll immediately you get a
15-day free trial to all my listeners
all right you'll have access to 8,000
video games at your fingertips they can
be delivered to your door or straight to
your PC WWE games live.com for 15 days
after 15 days of playing 8000 video
games if that's even possible you can be
like yeah you know what I don't want it
go to hell
why wouldn't you do that huh you know
why because you self-sabotage and you
have to stop and it begins today with
gamefly.com slash / alright that's the
podcast for this week congratulations to
everybody who's team who won in the
playoffs and my condolences even to the
Rangers man I just break you guys balls
okay that's it that's the podcast let's
go Celtics [ __ ] the Miami Heat and it's
gonna crush me to see the Spurs win the
championship again this year because I
always felt Tim Duncan should have been
a Celtic he was he's the perfect Celtic
fundamentally sound not flashy the anti
Showtime Laker it's what made that the
Celtics Lakers rivalry so great they
were both awesome teams who did it two
different ways
and we were always the we're gonna bore
you to death and still score 108 points
that's how we always were and just
forget there was some [ __ ] that
happened that year in the lottery we had
like two lottery balls and we still
didn't [ __ ] get him I don't know who
the [ __ ] we went to and wound up with
like Jill Barry Carroll or some [ __ ]
so it kills me
and you know what it's I you know what I
think do you think maybe San Antonio
will finally get some [ __ ] respect if
they win it again would this be Tim
Duncan's fourth or fifth title I can't
remember he won in 99
then they won in like Oh for then they
want to like they won like every other
year for a couple years I've know I
gotta look that up
I got no idea I should know that [ __ ] he
won at least three Oh bill shut the [ __ ]
up all right go [ __ ] yourself so I'll
talk to you next week
you